hey how you doing
excited
oh i can't imagine so i know that we're
recording yeah let's just get right into
this your very first oscar nomination
how are you feeling
i'm i'm so
elated right now i'm just excited
everyone's uh congratulating me
uh this is such a great feeling oh my
god will smith my fellow philadelphians
is hitting me up right now this is the
best day ever i'm so happy
did you just get a message from will
smith is that what you said
yeah
what did he say we've been we've been
you know we've we've been uh consoling
each other we're kind of nervous about
we're nervous about this morning so uh
you know he's been
uh
kind of coaching me through this process
telling me to wake up at four in the
morning and
meditate and look at the sky and all
those things so i've been doing that so
that's good advice what's so exciting
about this this is your directorial
debut
yeah i mean
that doesn't always happen for people
it doesn't but you know like summer of
seoul is is such a passionate uh
you know it's a passionate project and
that's the thing you you have to put
your passion in your heart
and to do something you know this is
part of the this part of the ride is
just
you know this is the cherry on top but
you know going into this my my only
concern was to restore history
uh and to really bring black joy and
happiness uh to the world that didn't
get this moment you know yeah uh do you
have high expectations for how jimmy
fallon is going to celebrate
[Laughter]
everybody uh at the tonight show is very
very happy for me um i feel like this is
my birthday all over again it was my
birthday last week but now it's like i
get a redo so
um no there's everyone's text to me
congratulations you know
so when all the press is done today what
are you gonna do
ah well i don't know i'm just gonna you
know probably have a nice dinner with my
girlfriend and my two cats and
and uh just relax
i love that class so nice getting to
talk to you congratulations
thank you so much thank you i appreciate
it